what is quantitative research and what
does the research process look like in a
quantitative study we'll go over that in
this video Let's Start what is
quantitative research quantitative
research is a research method for the
quantitative collection and Analysis of
data for the quantitative collection and
Analysis of data they are clearly
defined steps which precede one after
the other we'll go through the steps in
more detail in a moment what is the aim
of quantitative research
with quantitative research you want to
gain knowledge about reality
respectively check existing knowledge in
order to gain knowledge about reality or
to check it you must first collect data
and analyze data of course if you want
to check existing knowledge about
reality you must of course also
determine what is to be tested we will
now go into all three areas let's start
with the data collection for data
collection in quantitative research
quantitative methods are used from which
numerically measurable data emerge to
collect the data you use for example
surveys or experiments in a
questionnaire for example one question
could be how satisfied are you with the
current online teaching very satisfied
rather satisfied rather dissatisfied or
very dissatisfied so you would Define
the possible answer options now when you
send out your survey and get the results
you will receive your data in a
structured form
each row is a respondent every column is
a question and each cell takes on a
distinct value here you asked for
example for gender salary and age of
your respondents
for example the first person is female
and has an income of 1 500 euros
but what do you do with the data
depending on the insights you want to
gain you can either work in a
descriptive hypothesis testing or
exploratory way let's start with the
descriptive statistics based on your
population you draw a sample you then
describe the sample with the help of
descriptive statistics but how do you
describe the data in a descriptive work
you use statistical characteristics like
the mean value the standard deviation or
frequencies to describe your sample note
you cannot make a statement about the
population in this way of course in
descriptive statistics you use also
diagrams to visualize your results
what does this look like in the
hypothesis testing study in a hypothesis
testing study you want to use the
collected data to test hypotheses about
the population
in order to test these hypotheses about
the population on the basis of a sample
you use a hypothesis test this could be
for example a t-test an analysis of
variance or a correlation analysis and
finally in an exploratory study you want
to identify unknown patterns from the
data collected for this you use for
example a cluster analysis
of course you can also combine the three
areas of descriptive hypothesis testing
and exploratory in a thesis it is common
to describe your data descriptively and
then test your hypotheses using
hypothesis tests
but now we have omitted a very important
part what about the literature research
and what about the theories needed with
quantitative research you want to test a
statement about reality although it is
only a small section of reality this
small section is usually very complex
therefore an attempt is made to
establish statements or theories that
are free of contradictions
so reality is very complex therefore
simplified theories
but how do I get the theories I need
to get the theories you need you do an
extensive literature search you can then
derive your hypotheses from the theories
the hypotheses are then formulated in
such a way that they can be tested using
collected data of course you have to do
the literature review at the very
beginning of your research activities
in a quantitative research there is a
clearly structured research process
which we will now roughly go through we
then cover each step in detail in the
other videos in this playlist
at the very beginning you have to find a
research topic then comes the literature
research in practice these two steps are
often carried out in parallel and not
one after the other it is helpful to
combine the search for a suitable
research topic and the literature search
from the literature research you can
work out the state of research and the
theoretical background and derive your
hypotheses then you come to your
research design here you define how you
want to answer your research problem
usually however there's not much to do
here we know that we want to work
quantitatively and in most cases you
want to work descriptively and use
hypothesis testing then there is the
question of where you get your data from
after you've formulated your hypotheses
you still have to Define how to make the
variables that appear in your hypotheses
measurable this is the task of
operationalization this can be very
trivial as with age or gender you just
ask for it so in this case you would ask
how old are you what is your gender
for so-called latent variables however
which are not directly measurable such
as environmental well-being or physical
health this is associated with more
effort
then comes the data collection most of
the time you use a survey or an
experiment for this after data
collection comes the important part of
data preparation only when data is clean
you can move on to data analysis finally
there is the presentation of the results
we will now go into all points in more
detail in the following videos we will
start with how to find a suitable
research topic and what you should look
out for thanks for watching and see you
soon